The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: In
this lecture, we
will begin the discussion
of the computation
of the discrete
Fourier transform.
This is an extremely
important topic
in this set of lectures
for a number of reasons.
One of the reasons is that the
principal algorithm that we'll
be discussing, the
algorithm, which
we'll refer to as the fast
Fourier transform algorithm,
relies, for its
derivation, on many
of the properties of the
discrete Fourier transform.
And so, in fact,
developing this algorithm,
provides us with an
opportunity to exercise
some of the intuition and
some of the results related
to discrete Fourier transforms.
Of much more
practical importance
is the fact that the
fast Fourier transform
algorithm, which
we'll be presenting,
is a highly efficient
algorithm for computing
the discrete Fourier transform.
And in fact, as we'll
see, it is orders
of magnitude more efficient
than a straightforward direct
computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
Now, We've indicated
in previous lectures,
and you can well imagine
that this is true,
that there are many
contexts in which we
would want to explicitly compute
the discrete Fourier transform.
For example, obviously,
in spectral analysis
of discrete time
data, we would want
to use the computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
And we've seen also that the
discrete Fourier transform can
be used for the implementation
of finite impulse response
digital filters, or more
generally, can be used
to implement a convolution.
It will turn out that because of
the efficiency of the algorithm
that we'll be discussing
in these lectures, it,
in fact, in many cases is
more efficient to implement
the convolution by explicitly
computing a discrete Fourier
transform, multiplying
the transforms together,
and then Inverse transforming
the result. Of course,
keeping track of the
fact that that implements
a circular convolution and
doing the necessary things that
need to be done if
we're interested
in a linear convolution.
Now, I'd like, just
briefly, to remark
that this algorithm,
this-- actually, it's
a class of
algorithms, which I'll
refer to as the fast Fourier
transform algorithms,
were a major landmark
in the development
of the field of digital signal
processing in its present form.
The algorithm, one of the
forms of the algorithm,
was disclosed in a paper by
Cooley and Tukey in 1965.
And it turns out, though,
that the algorithm
has, in a variety of forms,
been reinvented several times
over the past 20 or 30 years.
So it is mainly this
class of algorithms
that we'll be talking about
in the next several lectures.
And I stress again that one
of the primary reasons why
this is so important is
because of the rather dramatic
improvements in
efficiency that it
offers over just
a straightforward
computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
Well, let's look
specifically at what's
involved in the computation of
the discrete Fourier transform.
The discrete Fourier
transform, as we know,
is given by the sum of
x sub n times W sub n
to the nk, where W sub n is
the complex exponential, e
to the minus j, 2
pi over capital n.
So it is this expression
that we want to compute.
Or equivalently, there is
the inverse discrete Fourier
transform given by
1 over capital N
times the sum of
x of k, the DFT,
times W sub N to the minus nk.
Now, hopefully you recall
from the discussion
of the discrete
Fourier transform,
that the inverse DFT
is really the same
as the discrete Fourier
transform if we reverse
the result in N, et cetera.
In other words, computation
of the inverse DFT
is really essentially the same
as the computation of the DFT.
So whereas we'll be
referring the discussion
to the computation of the
discrete Fourier transform,
essentially
everything that we say
applies also to a computation
of the inverse DFT.
Well, let's look,
first of all, at what
would be involved in
just a straightforward
computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
Basically what this expression
says is to take x of n,
multiply it by the
appropriate powers of W,
and then sum the result
from 0 to capital N minus 1.
And so, we basically
have that set
of operations to carry out for
each value of k for which we're
computing the discrete
Fourier transform.
Well, if we think of x
of n as being complex,
which in the most
general case it will be,
then we have in the direct
computation of the DFT,
we have to form the product, x
of n times W sub N to the nk.
And what that involves is
one complex multiplication.
This is a complex number.
That's a complex number.
Multiplying the two is
then one complex multiply,
or equivalently, four real
multiplies and two real adds.
OK, well now that is to
form one term in the sum.
We have n terms altogether
in the sum, or capital N
minus one additions,
complex additions,
to implement in the sum.
So to compute the DFT
for one value of k
will require capital N complex
multiplications and capital
N minus 1 complex additions.
Well to compute the
discrete Fourier transform
for all capital N values
of k requires then
n squared complex
multiplies and n times
n minus 1 complex additions.
Or basically if capital N
is any reasonable number,
we can approximate
this as N squared.
And so, approximately,
the computation involved
is on the order of capital
N squared complex multiplies
and adds.
Now, a few remarks here.
One, first of all, is
that in counting up
the number of complex
multiplies and adds,
we didn't particularly take
account of multiplies by unity.
For example, when k is equal
to 0, W sub N to the nk
is equal to unity,
and we, in fact,
wouldn't have to carry
out a multiplication.
But there are a
small enough number
of those cases in comparison to
all of the multiplies involved
so that this is generally
an indication of what
the dependence of the
computation is on N.
Second of all, and this will
occur throughout this next set
of lectures, we are
tying a discussion
of the computational complexity
or efficiency to counting
the number of complex
multiplies and adds
that are involved in the
computation of x of k,
and not particularly focusing on
other issues, such as indexing,
bookkeeping, et cetera.
So in discussing the
computational complexity
or efficiency,
we'll tend to refer
to the number of
multiplications and adds
that are involved in
implementing the transform.
Well, we have then a
direct computation,
which involves on the order of
n squared complex multiplies
and adds.
And the important point
then is its dependency on N,
namely N squared.
There are a variety
of algorithms
that have been known
for some time, in fact,
and ones that you
can generate yourself
by taking advantage of
various symmetry properties
of these complex exponentials.
To reduce the constant
of proportionality
on the computation, that is,
to make the computation perhaps
not involve N squared multiplies
and adds but only 1/2 N squared
or 1/4 N squared.
But still, in cases like
that, the algorithms
involved basically
fooling around
with a constant of
proportionality out in front,
whereas the main dependence on
N, the size of the transform,
remains the same.
And you can, I think, convince
yourself rather quickly
with some fairly
standard computers
that if, in fact, the
computation to be done
is proportional to N squared,
then very large transforms
certainly aren't possible
in very reasonable amounts
of time.
For example, if N is
on the order of 1,000,
then we're talking about
on the order of a million
complex multiplies and adds.
And if we assume that
one of those took,
say, two microseconds or three
microseconds to implement,
or even one microsecond,
then clearly we're
talking about computation
on the order of seconds.
And you can convince
yourself rather quickly
that the computation grows very
fast as N increases from 1,000
to 2,000 to 4,000, et cetera.
All right, so direct
computation, the dependency
is an n squared
type of dependency.
And this is in contrast
to the primary algorithm
that we want to discuss, which
is the fast Fourier transform
algorithm.
Basically, the fast
Fourier transform algorithm
is directed at computing the
discrete Fourier transform
for a choice of N, the
size of the transform,
highly composite.
That is, N is, in general--
of course, any N
can be represented
as a product of primes.
And as we'll see, the
larger the number of primes
involved in the
decomposition of N,
the greater the efficiency
of the fast Fourier
transform as an algorithm for
computing the discrete Fourier
transform.
In particular, we'll see that
for N, a product of primes,
using the fast Fourier
transform algorithm,
the number of complex
multiplies and additions
involved will turn out to
be proportional not to N
squared as it is in
the direct computation,
but proportional to N
times a sum of the primes
involved in that decomposition
of N. So the greater the number
of primes that we can decompose
N in and the smaller each
of those primes, the higher the
efficiency of the fast Fourier
transform algorithm will be.
Well,
The most highly composite that
we can make N, and at the same
time keeping the primes,
p, as small as possible,
is to choose N to
be a power of 2.
So that N is of the
form 2 the nu, where
nu is the log to the base 2
of N. And it will turn out,
in that case, that the complex
multiplies and additions
is proportional to N
times log to the base 2 N,
rather than, in the
direct computation,
proportional to N squared.
Let me incidentally
comment that although I've
referred to these p's as
primes, they, in fact,
don't have to be primes.
The important
issue, as we'll see,
is that N be representable
as a product of numbers.
And it's not
particularly important
that those numbers
turn out to be primes.
Well, OK, so this then
is the kind of efficiency
that we will get out of the fast
Fourier transform algorithm.
And let me begin the
discussion of the algorithm
by concentrating on the case
in which N is a power of 2.
Well, basically, the idea behind
the fast Fourier transform
algorithm is to
decompose the computation
of the discrete
Fourier transform
into a set of subsequences.
And this is-- this
generates a class of forms
for the algorithm,
which are referred
to as decimation-in-time
forms of the algorithm.
In particular, suppose
that we consider
decomposing the
original sequence x of n
into two subsequences.
One sequence,
subsequence, consists
of the even-numbered
points of x of n.
And the second
subsequence consists
of the odd-numbered
points of x of n.
Well, let's just do that
and see where it gets us.
We can then rewrite the
discrete Fourier transform
as a sum over n even
of x of n times W sub N
to the nk plus the
sum over n odd of x
of n W sub N to the nk.
Simply pulling out from this
the even-numbered values
and the odd-numbered values.
All right, now by a
substitution of variables,
we can substitute for n 2 r
in the even-numbered terms.
And we can substitute
n equals 2 r plus 1
for the odd-number
terms, in which case,
when we convert these two
sums over r, the sum on r
will now range from 0 to
capital N over 2 minus 1.
As r runs from 0 to
capital N over 2 minus 1,
2 r ranges over the
even-numbered terms, and 2 r
plus 1 ranges over the
odd-numbered terms.
All right, so making the
substitution of variables then,
this sum is converted
into a sum from r equals 0
to N over 2 minus 1.
x of 2r W sub N to
the 2rk plus a sum--
those are the
even-numbered terms--
plus a sum over the
odd-numbered terms from 0
to n over 2 minus
1. x of 2r plus 1,
the odd-numbered points, times W
sub N to the 2r plus 1 times k.
Well, let's look at this factor.
W sub N to the 2r
plus 1 times k,
that's equal to W sub N to
the k, because of the 1,
and W sub N to the 2rk.
So we can, first of
all, break this term up
into a product of
these two terms.
And now, let's look at this
one, W sub N to the 2rk.
Well, W sub N squared is
equal to e to the minus j
2 pi over capital N squared.
So the factor of 2.
If we take the 2 down
in the denominator
and associate it with the
N, we can rewrite this as e
to the minus j 2 pi over N/2.
So what W sub N squared is equal
to is W sub capital N over 2.
In other words, the W that we
would associate with an N/2
point discrete
Fourier transform.
Finally, substituting
this together
with this statement back
into this expression,
we have, for x of k, the
sum from 0 to N/2 minus 1,
x of 2r W sub N over
2 to the rk plus W sub
N to the k times the sum of
x of 2r plus 1 W sub N over 2
to the rk.
Well, what this looks like is
an N/2 point discrete Fourier
transform.
And what this looks
like is an N/2
point discrete
Fourier transform.
And in fact, that's
what they are.
This is an N/2 point DFT
of the even-numbered points
in a sequence x of n.
This is an N/2 point of
the odd-numbered points
in the sequence x of n.
So this says we
can compute x of k
by computing an N/2 point
DFT, another N/2 point DFT,
and combining those two
together with this factor
out in front, W sub N to the k.
Now, it's not
particularly obvious
yet that, in fact,
in doing this,
we've saved something
in computation.
But let's look at
what this implies
in terms of the computational
steps in a little more detail.
So here we have, again,
X of k as an N/2 point
DFT involving the
even-numbered points in x of n
plus an N/2 point DFT involving
the odd-numbered points in x
of n.
Those are both N/2 point DFTs.
This one, if we
refer to as G of k,
this one, if we
refer to as H of k,
then the computation
of the DFT, X of k
is G of k plus W sub N
to the k times H of k.
All right, let's
see what this means
in terms of computation,
computational complexity.
We have to compute
an N/2 point DFT.
We just argued that
an endpoint DFT
involves N squared complex
multiplies and adds.
So the computation
of G of k involves
N/2 squared complex
multiplies and adds.
The computation of H of
k involves, likewise,
N/2 squared complex
multiplies and adds.
So we have then 2 times
N/2 squared multiplies
and adds due to the computation
of these two N/2 point DFT.
In addition, we have to
combine these together
by multiplying by
W sub N to the k.
That involves capital
N complex multiplies
and adds, because k ranges
from 0 to N minus 1.
In other words, k ranges
over N different values.
So there are N complex
multiplies involved in this,
and then N complex adds in
combining these together.
So in addition to the
computation of the two N/2
point DFTs, we have the
combination of them.
And the resulting computation
involves N plus N squared over
2 complex multiplies and adds.
And you can convince yourself
on the back of an envelope
very quickly that this
number will always turn out
to be less than N
squared, except, I
think, for some trivial cases
like N equals 1 or N equals 2.
Now, one minor
point to be made--
in combining these
two together, I
commented that k has to run
from 0 to capital N minus 1.
That is, there are N different
values that k ranges over,
so doesn't that say that
in computing G of k,
I can't just compute it from
k equals 0 to n over 2 minus 1
as I normally would
in computing a DFT?
Don't I have to compute it
from 0 all the way up to N
or all the way up to N minus 1?
Well, sure I do.
I do, because those
are the values that I
need in here and in here.
But what does that imply
in terms of computation?
Well, we know that an N/2
point DFT is periodic in k,
so that if we compute
only the first N/2 points,
we know that the
next N/2 points are
going to look exactly the same.
And so, there's no
point in computing them.
So the point then is
that in computing G of k
for this computation,
even though we want k
to run from 0 to
N minus 1, we only
need to explicitly do
this computation for k
from 0 to N over 2 minus 1.
And then we simply use
those values over again
for the second range from
k from N/2 to N minus 1.
And that, by the way,
is the essential key
in the fast Fourier
transform algorithm.
It's basically that periodicity
in the discrete Fourier
transform that will
lead to the kind
of computational efficiency
that's about to result.
All right, so let's look
then at how we would actually
do the computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
We know then that we will
break the computation
into a computation involving
the even-numbered points and x
of n and the odd-numbered
points and x of n.
Compute an N/2 point
discrete Fourier transform
to obtain the sequence
G of k, another N/2
point discrete Fourier transform
to compute the sequence H of k,
and then combine the results
together by multiplying H of k
by W sub N to the k and
adding that to G of k.
I'll illustrate the
computation, incidentally,
with choosing N
equal to 8, simply
because I have to choose
N equal to something.
And it turns out,
interestingly enough,
that N equals 8 is
sufficiently general,
so that you can infer
the generality for N
equal to an arbitrary
power of 2 just
from the computational
issues that we'll
raise for this particular case.
All right, so we
have N/2 point DFT
of the even-numbered
points, the N/2
point DFT of the
odd-numbered points.
And now, to compute the output
points, the discrete Fourier
transform, X of k, we
then want to take G of 0
and add it to H of 0
multiplied by W sub N to the 0.
So using flow graph
notation, we have
G of 0 added to H of 0
multiplied by W sub N so the 0.
For x of 1, we want G
of 1 added to H of 1
multiplied by W sub N to the 1.
For x of 2, we want
G of 2 plus H of 2
multiplied by W sub N squared.
And for x of 3,
likewise, G of 3 added
to H of 3 multiplied
by W sub N cubed.
So that computation, then,
gives us x of 0 through x of 3.
For x of 4, we want G of 4 plus
W sub N to the 4 times H of 4.
But what's G of 4?
G of 4 is equal to G of 0,
because of the fact that G of k
is periodic with period 4.
This is a four-point DFT
that we're computing.
So G of k is periodic
with period 4.
And consequently, H of 4 and
G of 4 are equal to H of 0
and G of 0.
So to compute the
next four points,
we can likewise use the outputs
of these N/2 point DFTs.
To compute x of 4, we want G
of 4, which is equal to G of 0,
because of the periodicity,
plus W sub N to 4 times H of 4.
H of 4 is equal to H of 0.
So we have then for x of
4, G of 0 plus W sub N
to 4 times H of 0.
Likewise, for x of 5, we
have G of 5, or G of 1,
plus W sub N to the 5th
times H of 5, or H of 1
because of the periodicity,
and likewise, down
through the remaining
four points.
So we showed previous--
on the previous view
graph, the computation
for the first four points.
And here we have the computation
for the last four points.
Putting those two together
then, the computation
for the eight-point DFT
is, as I've indicated here,
the even-numbered
points into an N/2 point
DFT, the odd-numbered points
into an N/2 point DFT,
and the results
combined together
according to the computation
that we've shown here.
Now, a couple of
things that I'd like
to draw your attention to
about the flow graph as it's
developing.
First of all, note
that the flow graph,
as we're looking at it here,
involves a computation, which
if we were to just pull out
the computation of these two
points, or these two
points, et cetera,
it has the structure of a set of
butterfly-looking flow graphs.
And, in fact, we'll find
it convenient to refer
to these as butterflies
in the computation.
The second thing that I'd
like to draw your attention to
is that the multiplications
by powers of W
always are applied to
the branches which come
from this bottom transform.
And that's because we had
the expression that X of k
was equal to G of k plus W
sub N to the k times H of k,
and this was the H of k.
So it's in the bottom
branch of these butterflies
that we see always
the multiplication
by these powers of
W. And I say that, I
want to point that out hit
now, because it's somewhat
difficult in drawing these
flow graphs to always get
these powers of W close
enough to the arrow
so that it's clear where
the computation, where
the multiplication
needs to be carried out.
All right, so here's
where we're at.
We had counted out
previously the number
of complex multiplies
and adds involved,
and we found that it was on
the order of N plus 2 times
and over 2 squared, which
is less than N squared.
And consequently, this
is a more efficient way
to compute the discrete
Fourier transform than simply
a direct computation.
However, like this
assumes that we're
going to compute these N/2 point
DFTs as a direct computation.
But in fact, if N/2
is a composite number,
in particular a
power of 2, which
it is if N was a
power of 2, then we
can apply the same strategy to
the computation of these N/2
point DFTs.
So we can break these N/2
point DFT computations into--
each one of these--
into two N/4 point
DFTs plus some
additional arithmetic
in order to form
the N/2 point DFTs.
So each one of
the N/2 point DFTs
can then be decomposed into
an N/4 point DFT computation,
into two N/4 point
DFT computations.
In particular, we had,
recall, for the top half
of the previous view graph,
the even-numbered points
in the original sequence.
All right, now we want
to compute the DFT
of those even-numbered points.
So we can go through
exactly the same steps.
We can break that into
its even-numbered points
and its odd numbered points.
So we have the even numbered
of the even-numbered points
into an N/4 point
DFT, the odd numbered
of the even-numbered points
into a second N/4 point DFT,
and then those
results are combined
in exactly the same way as the
N/2 point DFTs were combined
in the previous view
graph, but now with N/2
as the subscript rather
than N as the subscript,
because here what we're
computing is an N/2 point DFT.
However, in drawing
the flow graph,
we can re-express the
powers of W sub N over 2
in terms of powers of W
sub N, because of the fact
that W sub N squared is equal
to W sub N over 2 or vice versa.
All right, so we
have this then apply
to the even-numbered points
and to the odd-numbered points.
And when we do
that, then the flow
graph that results is
as I've indicated here.
We have the even numbered
of the even-numbered points
and the odd numbered of
the even-numbered points.
We have the even numbered
of the odd-numbered points
and the odd numbered of
the odd-numbered points.
Those are each going
into N/4 point DFTs.
Here is then the
sequence G of k.
I'm sorry.
Here is the sequence G of k.
Here is the sequence H of k.
This then implements the
computation of the N/2 point
DFTs that we had before.
And then we have the output DFT
obtained by combining those.
So this flow graph results
from simply carrying
the previous strategy back one
step to implementing the N/2
point DFTs.
All right, well, now we have the
computation of N/4 point DFTs.
And we can do exactly the same
thing with the N/4 point DFTs,
except that for this
particular example, N/4--
if N is equal to 8,
N/4 is equal to 2.
The computation of
the two-point DFTs
is a relatively
straightforward thing.
But in general, if
N wasn't equal to 8,
if it was a more
general power of 2,
we could likewise
apply this strategy
to the computation of the N/4
point DFTs, the N/8 point DFTs,
and over 16 point
DFTs, et cetera,
until we got to the
computation of two-point DFTs.
All right, so just simply
inserting the computation
for these two-point DFTs,
which involves simply adding--
well, adding x of 4 to x
of 0, multiplying x of 4
by W sub N to the 4 and
adding it to x of 0.
The resulting flow graph
for the entire computation
is as I show here, where we
have now the input points.
We have the output points.
Here we're computing
the two-point DFTs,
combining those together
to get the four-point DFTs,
combining those together to
get the eight-point DFTs,
et cetera.
And I'll remind you again that
the basic computation that's
involved throughout these stages
is the butterfly computation.
We see it here, we see it
here, and we see it here.
And always, the
multiplication by powers of W
is applied to the branches
coming from the bottom node
of the butterfly.
And that's because of
the fact that X of k
is expressed as G of k plus W
sub N to the k times H of k.
And it's always the
H of Ks that are
what are being computed
in the bottom half
as we've been developing
this flow graph.
It will turn out that that's
not true for other forms
of the algorithm, but for the
form that we're developing here
it is.
All right, well,
having carried this
all the way back to
the two-point DFTs,
let's see what this has
accomplished for us in terms
of computational efficiency.
We began with N equal
to a power of 2.
We thought about computing
a direct discrete Fourier
transform, but that involved
N squared complex multiplies
and adds.
Instead of that, we
broke the computation
into two N/2 point
DFTs plus some diddling
to fit those together.
The computation of
the two N/2 point DFTs
involved complex multiplies
and adds equal to 2,
because there were two of
them, times N/2 squared
plus N for the diddles--
the diddles being involved in
fitting those two N/2 point
DFTs together.
And this, for N
greater than two,
is a bigger number than that.
All right, then we said,
well, why stop there?
Let's break these two N/2 point
DFTs into four N/4 point DFTs.
That meant then that
this N/2 squared, which
came from a direct
computation of the DFT,
gets replaced instead
by two N/4 point DFTs.
So we have 2 times N/4
squared plus N/2, which
are the diddles involved in,
again, fitting those together.
So the N/2 squared, which
involved computing one N/2
point DFT gets
replaced by this when
we go to the N/4 point DFTs.
And consequently,
substituting this in there,
the computation is--
instead of that,
it's N/4 squared
times 4 plus N plus N. This
N coming from that 2 times
this N/2.
Well, we can go
through this again.
We broke the N/4 point
DFTs into N/8 point DFTs.
Therefore, the N/4 squared
got replaced by N/8
squared twice, plus N/4
to fit those together.
That gets substituted
in for this N/4 squared.
We get 8 times N/8 squared.
We pick up another N, which
is this 4 times that N/4.
And you can see that
each time we do this,
this number gets smaller,
and we keep picking up
another factor of N added in.
Well, if you track this through,
what you find is that for N
equal to a power of 2, in
fact, the computation then
comes out proportional to
N plus N plus N nu times,
where nu is log for
the base 2 of N.
And so, the number of complex
multiplies and adds involved
in implementing the
discrete Fourier transform
using the fast Fourier transform
algorithm is proportional to N
times nu rather than
proportional to N squared.
A rather dramatic savings.
OK, well there is one--
there are a number
of modifications
that we're going to want to
make to this basic structure
for the computation as we
go through this lecture
and the next several lectures.
The first is to introduce
a fairly straightforward
simplification by,
first of all, again,
reminding you that the basic
computation involved always,
from one stage to
the next, is always
a butterfly type of computation
with multiplications
by powers of W applied to the
signal from the bottom node.
And you should notice, and
it's rather straightforward
to verify why this
is true, that in each
of these butterflies,
the separation in powers
of W between the factor going
to the top node at the end
of the butterfly
and the factor going
to the bottom node
in the butterfly,
they are always
separated by N/2.
So that means that the basic
computation in the computation
of the DFT, as I illustrated
on the previous flow graph,
is a butterfly, where
the characteristic of it
is that it's multiplication
by unity from the top node,
and multiplication by some
power of W from the bottom
to the top node, and a power
of W displaced from this one
by N/2 from the bottom
node to the bottom node.
Well, let's decompose
this power of W
into W sub N to the r
times W sub N to the N/2.
W sub N to the N/2.
Well, what is that?
That's e to the minus j
2 pi over capitalized N--
that's W sub N--
raised to the N/2 power.
The capital N's cancel out.
The 2's cancel out.
We're left with e to the minus
j pi, which is equal to minus 1.
So then, in fact, this factor,
or equivalently, this factor,
is equal to minus 1 or
minus W sub N to the r.
Consequently, we could
redraw the butterfly
so that rather than implementing
that multiplication in both
the branch going to the
top node and the branch
going to the bottom
node, we simply
multiply the value
coming into the butterfly
by W sub N to the
r, and then add it
to this value at the top
node, and subtract it
from this value at
the bottom node.
So we could redraw our
original flow graph
by replacing the
butterfly computation
in the previous flow graph by
this butterfly computation,
where the multiplication
by the power of W
is extracted from
inside the butterfly,
so that basically we reduce the
number of multiplications by W
that we have to implement
by a factor of 2.
The flow graph that results when
we do that we have here then,
where the powers of W are
now slid out of the butterfly
to the entering node
to the butterfly.
And we now have, rather
than multiplication
by powers of W in the butterfly,
each butterfly computation
consists of an addition
and a subtraction.
So the basic computation
now is a multiplication
by a power of W followed by
an addition and a subtraction.
And this follows all the
way through a multiplication
by a power of W and then an
addition and a subtraction,
this minus 1 being
associated with this line.
The minus 1's, of
course, always occur
on the branches coming from the
bottom node of the butterfly.
That's consistent
with everything
that we've been saying
throughout this discussion.
All right, so this then is
one form of an algorithm,
referred to as the fast
Fourier transform algorithm,
for implementing the computation
of the discrete Fourier
transform.
As the algorithm developed, it
developed somewhat naturally
in a flow graph form.
And in fact, we can
interpret this flow graph
as a computational
recipe for computing
the discrete Fourier transform.
There are a few
things that I would
like to draw your attention to.
One primary one in particular
at this point, that
is that we notice that the
input sequence values, because
of the way that we derive this
algorithm, the input sequence
values got rearranged in
a somewhat funny order
at the input to the flow graph.
Although, they come
out of the flow
graph in a sequential order,
0, 1, 2, 3, et cetera.
Over here, it's an order
of 0, 4, 2, 6 1, 5, 3, 7.
It will turn out that that
order has a certain amount
of significance.
In fact, as we'll
see, as we continue
this discussion in the next
lecture, that this is in fact
a bit reversed order.
It corresponds to rearranging
the order of the bits
in the binary representation
of the indices.
And furthermore, it's
possible to interpret
this flow graph
in terms, not just
of the computation of the
discrete Fourier transform,
but it also suggests
how to arrange
the memory, that is, the
storage of the input sequence
and the resulting storage
of the output sequence.
There are some efficiencies
that result when we do that.
And that's one of
the first topics
that we'll begin with next time.
So in the next
lecture then, we will
continue on the development
of the fast Fourier transform
algorithm, picking
up from the point
that we've reached
so far, which is--
the point that we've
reached is to have
exposed one form of the fast
Fourier transform algorithm.
There are some important points
to be made about that form.
And then a variety of
modifications of that form
that have some advantages,
and, as it will turn out,
also some disadvantages.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]